what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're back week to week we
haven't missed a beat now one week have
we missed
last week's was great thank you all who
commented last week uh we're gonna watch
season four episode called Chasing Amy a
riff on the Kevin Bacon movie Chasing
Amy starring Matt Damon and yeah I don't
remember who else is in that movie you
got this trivia Champion
who's the one who looks like Jason Lee
but is not Jason Lee
Chris
the first other white guy came to mind I
know it's Kevin Smith and yeah I'm not
gonna explain my stupid sarcasm you guys
all right guys leave a like on this
video that mean a lot also I want to
thank everyone who has joined our
patreon page for this show your support
has been immensely recognized you are
worshiped amongst the royalty of the
reject nation and let let's just get
into action paper
foreign
[Music]
what's going on why is Amy's Hair like
that oh she obsessively braids her hair
when she's nervous and she's super
nervous because she's taking the
Sergeant's exam today but Amy loves
tests not this one uh-oh if she doesn't
pass this exam she's gonna have to wait
another three years to take it again and
that'll disrupt her entire life calendar
is that a real thing it hangs over our
bed cool it's like a one on the Santiago
Panic scale yeah but we've also jumped
up to level two creepily singing songs
from The Great American Songbook you're
a great
[Music]
but I think the worst is behind us
wow
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa that was a body this
would be rated R
hey babe no whoa I see you've taken the
braids out your hair looks fun now it's
ready for me to braid again okay like
Hermione from the book practice test you
Ace it you relax you nail the real one
you become a sergeant you make grateful
love to me for 14 hours straight Jake
fine one hour 15 minutes eight three but
they're mind blown
there's nothing to distract you I mean
look around a child could pass the
freaking MCAT in here which is why I've
asked these officers to do their
paperwork in here while you take the
test he writes way too loudly she's
always yawning he has a gross cold she
has a weird arm stretching thing oh good
and Hitchcock and Scully with two hours
worth of potato chips oh my God yummy
they're gonna die a witness just came in
with a child while she was being
interviewed I took the kid to the soft
room and the toy situation in there is
kind of Bleak is this your opinion or
the child's opinion it's mine trick
question any opinion about toys is a
child's opinion all we have in there are
toys from the movie Kazam and none of
them are even Kazam get a Shaq action
figure maybe add a model train I used to
love him when I was a kid I was also a
model train Enthusiast as a child those
miniature tracks provided me with some
of my happiest memories
all aboard the train will be departing
in 45 minutes
[Music]
I like this idea Jeffers I'll help you
build the train set sweet this will be
fun I hope not
strings
what if it's a Kazam drink Hannah Boyle
recently passed yes I watched the live
stream of the plug pulling ceremony
guess what she left me no her silk bed
sheets
don't get jealous she left you something
too so nice of her and it's a big jar of
brown sludge that smells like death oh
come out of her
it's fast for 140 years the bread it
births is succulent and firm Tang for
days I hate so many of the words you
just used succulent
I barely knew her you know what she
probably got you confused with my cousin
Tina he was always her favorite Tina has
a boy's name yeah a short for Christina
you're right
well done I know how badly you want this
so you're gonna have to pay for it we
don't even want that you said it smelled
like death I thought it did but now
smells like opportunity God it really
does smell bad my eyes hurt
Amy left and asked me to give you this
note she go out to get us more chips no
the practice test freaked her out she's
not taking the Sergeant's exam
it's a great timing if you were Amy
where would you be right now oh um
boring pant suit store a crossword
Factory a museum of retainers and
headgear
I'll be Amy just know everything I'm
about to say I say with love okay I'm
outside it's 78 degrees and yet somehow
I'm still cold better Walk On the Sunny
Side of the Street
did I remember to put on sunscreen pasta
thing pause to think yes I did put on
sunscreen and I bragged about it all
morning Amy's on the move and I'm
walking
[Laughter]
diesel locomotive with sprung Drive
wheels and full underbody detailing
you're going to be the bell of the ball
Terry is your god blue
oh Lord Terry
check out Jeffords Junction it's got an
ice cream shop a 50s diner and a Mexican
restaurant with a sombrero on it this
does not work I'm just trying to build a
fun world that's what model trains are
all about imagination no they're about
accuracy people want to see the world
around them exactly as it is but smaller
okay we can have part of the model be
very accurate and part of it will be
creative yes yes as am I uh would you
fetch me the eight millimeter level from
my office oh sure fool
Shepherds I thought you were a god
ah
oops
you somehow lucked your way into a
family heirloom and have the gall to ask
me to give you ten thousand dollars for
it that's an absurd amount of money took
me all morning to get it together of
course I've changed my mind I want to
keep the mother dough I'm going to start
baking I see what you're doing you're
trying to up the price
well shame on you
but also here you go you won't get one
cent more
after this
what's going on nothing I just realized
that I love old sour bread so much come
on Gina I put it under my desk and my
space heater Burns it to a crisp oh
listen you got to get over it was just
some old bread batter it had black spots
in it those are the sour spores that's
where the Tang comes from
[Laughter]
you're ruining our model with your
frivolous garbage we're building this
for kids
really think they're going to enjoy your
brown rectangle of dirt
we have a witness coming in at three
o'clock with her son Let's split this
train set in two make our own models and
see which one he likes more I'm gonna
turn jeopard's Junction into the funnest
town in America that's right I said
funnest
improper English Stop Dancing
this is a direct order stop
dancing
of course I know what do they insist on
having our two black characters fight
against each other this is not the
progress we need I cannot believe you
screwed this up for her I was kind of
hoping for something more traditionally
positive as opposed to overtly negative
I like him just not as a boyfriend for
Amy or as a trivia teammate I tried my
hardest the phrase you're looking for is
winter is coming no what Paul Revere
said was that the British
[Laughter]
Department of Records so I'm going to
make an educated guess and say she came
here for a record not sure you're
qualified to make an educated couch a
theory of relativity question I just got
crazy hair super smart chewy name I
Eisenberg Jesse Eisenberg
I know lots of things I know the names
of every Transformer yeah even the
Dinobots Grimlock much no there was a
99th Precinct case File from January
2014 that was just accessed okay I
definitely know where she is like you
definitely knew the Serengeti was a type
of pasta Let It Go Kylie
uh yes now that's what I call the right
amount of air it's rubbery great job
Captain that's just what the kids gonna
want to play in a Serial Killer's
Dumping Ground all aboard the jeopards
victory Express wow that does look cool
Hello Dylan I'm captain Holt we have
some trains here to play with I like
this one that carries coal and rivets
the two main exports of our town would
you like to come over here to Jeffords
Junction where it's always all four
seasons and a volcano
he doesn't like trains at all do you
guys have any video games yeah okay
trains are kind of lame and nobody plays
with them okay but surely one of these
trains is less lame than the other right
no they look exactly the same oh
get out
[Music]
it's a beautiful delivery Tina Boyle is
contesting the will the mother dough is
to be placed in protective custody until
the matter is resolved Gina they will
banish you from the family no more boil
activities Aruba was the worst thing
that's ever happened how did all 18 of
you have sleep apnea
oh my God no
oh great jacket where'd you get it you
know I got it at mervin's where's my
mother dough yeah about that they're
like gangsters I killed her no I killed
her dad put her by a space heater until
she was burnt up to a black lump of coal
oh my God yeah that's right she gone the
picture of Italy you're banished from
the family oh no I love you I love you
too but you brought jean into this
family and you're also Banning what oh
no too far make it right Peralta and
Santiago conducted surveillance from a
rooftop at 397 Barton Street this is
where we came the night I won our bet
and you fell in love with me Jake the
night that you flirted with me for 20
seconds and I became obsessed with you
forever ready I remember this
when I passed the exam I'll actually be
a sergeant what if everything changes
between us
things are so good right now I don't
want to screw that up leave him
power
you can't be afraid to be successful
you're too good for that
I love you
too
wait the test we gotta get you out of
here right I'm gonna be a surgeon I'm
gonna be a sergeant yes
you don't have a key for this random
roof door do you
shoot it
the exam's in 20 minutes it's my fault
we're up here I just won't take the test
I'll wait three years for the next
one oh no you won't no Jake you are not
die Harding off this one I would
definitely die-harded off this roof
see in Hell kiddo what yes
air bars on the way now
turns out children don't care about
model trains not only children I'm
beginning to think nobody does Kevin you
are not going to believe this but low
the IRT Pullman Rolling Stock on a
ballastless track I was dying Kevin
dying yes you can hang up now
[Music]
I know we've had our differences but
through some crazy twist of fate we
found each other shouldn't we just be
excited that we have someone to share
that with not interested good day
well I just wanted to show you I got a
tiny little train inspector to make sure
the tracks were up the code
I'll be going you left your figurine
behind for some reason take it
gosh
wait come on Sergeant take the train to
the pass
this is when the boils went to that farm
and we all got hoof and mouth disease
ah when we went to that water park and
we all got hoof and mouth disease again
it's a new mother dough
Charles back into the family please how
are you to this new mother dough you can
not come by my apartment and take a
little piece whenever you want we need
keys why in case you're not home or in
the bath oh
you don't have to do this yes I do
because you're my brother oh isn't she
great we used to have sex you know cool
you don't have to mention that every
time you idiot it looks like Peter B
Parker I just want to thank you guys for
chasing me down and getting me here
I think I know how to make it up to you
three minutes oh no not that even better
okay trivia you said you would never
bring him again don't worry it's gonna
be fine I promise is it tonight's first
category by special requests Die Hard
Transformers movies
question one what is the name of the
evil race of Transformers the robot Bad
Robot oh God don't know oh sorry I can't
take the trivia press what could you
have just given me the three minutes
a lesson for all you women out there
that's right take the three always offer
the three
always always go for three always go for
the three men hate trivia that's right
don't forget that piece of information
dudes don't like to show off information
knowledge so Gina
has a heart
of gold looks like that bus accident my
what I want to do moving forward is make
sure that we serialize everything from a
psychological standpoint or it comes to
Brooklyn I think Gina as bus accident is
the thing that has led her to being much
more open and willing to have a change
of heart because she's realized life is
way too short and Family Matters more
than anything else and due to that
circumstantial event where she nearly
lost her life now when being faced with
a situation like this where her own
brother
has the possibility of being excluded
from the family due to her own mistake
she now realizes the consequences of
what's going on yeah that brush with
death has really brought out a
compassionate side of Gene and even
though she starts out by trying to
Swindle him and trying to cheat him out
of money eventually she comes to her
senses and in killing the doe is
reminded of how she could have turned
out after that bus crashed so yeah she
has done a full 180 as a character one
million percent dude and now with Holt
obviously the way he was raised was one
of lack of connection so when it came to
building trains all he ever knew how to
do was try to latch onto some type of
sense of reality and of course you know
with everything with Terry of having
such a childlike Wonder towards the
world even as sergeant at this Police
Department them finding this type of
kinship was the kind they couldn't find
growing up together you know I I get the
impression that Terry maybe didn't have
too many
male friends or masculine friends
growing up there seems to be a lot of
strong feminine qualities about Terry
even having daughters and such and now
this is the brother that he's been
looking for and I don't mean that and
only the fact that they're black sure
mainly but not just mainly but not only
that of course yeah just want to
underscore that a little bit and
obviously there's more going on there
than just holding on to what it was like
with your but it's also a fight to hold
on to what you preserved as a childhood
memory but even then it's a lesson about
growing up John yeah and it's also
growing up it's about growing up and
it's also about how to uh not abuse
power you know because think of it I
mean Holt we've seen him go on this
journey of being a lot more you know
straight laced as a chief but now he's
willing to kind of fly off the handle
and and you know really be Petty towards
his fellow officers and his subordinates
and if you didn't have a presence like
Terry to help bring his compassion back
to the Forefront you know and help fill
in that missing void you know Holt could
become a real monster and you know I
really felt the Peril of uh just
terrorists yeah absolutely I just felt
that permeating the episode when they
finally came together at the end it was
you know like a Reclamation of his
Spirit you know it's like even his
husband at home isn't supportive of one
of his main passions so true so true and
of course Amy where to begin where and
to begin where where do you look
everywhere outside no no you start
internally you look at the soul you take
that pocket knife out you carve open
that epidermis around your heart
your uh
vernacular
your vascular
array your and so you can ventricles see
what's really going on here you know her
whole life has been one of organization
you know being a bit controlling because
she grew up in a chaotic household or
I'm wrong about that her father was very
Stern and controlling considering the
kind of police officer he was yeah and
as his organization is that we can't
straight lace waves if the show told us
what their backstory is we have to
adhere to it because I want to make sure
that Brooklyn Nine-Nine is a serialized
experience for everyone uh so yeah with
Jimmy Smith being her father having this
sense of trying to be the best at what
you can be so always being very career
driven and now challenged challenged by
love absolutely you know and our parents
aren't together right I forget I don't
so right yeah you know why because
career and work got in the way that's
right and that's what this was reminding
her of her parents separating from each
other due to the fact that her dad who
she idolizes he made some miscalculated
choices
he chose the job and while she's
choosing the job she had to find the
right kind of partner meaning finding
someone who's not as ambitious yeah
finding someone's not as ambitious to
support and then you know with Jake
constantly trying to take care of his
mom who was abandoned by their dad he's
not going to make the same mistake his
father May he's going to support he's a
good boy his mom approval he wants that
enrichment of knowing that he's taking
care of her emotionally so that she can
go and take care of them financially you
are seeing their parents
redo their love story through them and
they don't even realize it bringing the
Symmetry together it's a beautiful
Timeless Love Story really when you look
at it and then you have you know the
help of a friend Rosa who doesn't even
steal the spotlight this episode but she
makes sure that Jake gets there so they
can save Amy from sabotaging her entire
future yeah yeah and putting aside the
violence of rose's past not to you know
kill trivia girl
so I mean the show's really really they
don't just go for the jokes people
almost never almost never they go really
for the details of the characters and in
this Canon Kazam is just Kazam and
nobody thought it was Shazam so that's
another thing that happened have you
seen Kazam I have seen Kazam
I mean you know I was like what eight
whenever it came out or whatever I've
seen multiple times really
[Music]
do you love it is it great I do is it
better than I remember everything that
happens in it do you
I could I could tell you beat by beat
that's a new series we should I can
quote Greg Recaps the plot quote it from
beginning to none oh good good you can
fill me in then yeah oh my God I can I
can only quote about three quarters of
it I know like the back of my hand
definitely which I'd be too but I would
say I know Kazam better than the back of
my head
I mean we should all be so lucky to know
anything as well as you know Kazam I
mean you know I'm a big Kazam fan
yeah you know he was the only guy
dressed up in that cosplay everywhere we
go you know any convention Greg's like I
gotta keep the Shazam level when you say
Kazam and you say cosplay I know exactly
what that outfit looks like sure Springs
to mind you can absolutely imagine
exactly the motifs and visuals one thing
I can illustrate from squirrel thing
only thing I can do yeah swirl I know
what you're referring to Sure thousand
percent little uh vest yeah there's a
there's a boy in there there's a boy
whose name I love and remembered an
actor who I constantly whose career I
follow
yeah yeah that was a good one I just
never stopped watching either of those
oh Steele is one of the most underrated
DC movies I think we've ever seen sure
John Henry Aaron's finally earning some
respect
all right guys well what did you think
about Brooklyn nine nine uh I thought
this was another fun episode I hope you
had fun too
and we're here to provide something
different to the experience that others
just will not tell you
because let's face it
they're all they're not they
don't want to talk about the real
not like us
we find the drama within the comedy yeah
and we find the comedy within the drama
that's right so one works out a lot
better than the other yeah
when we get called insensitive for
but you couldn't take it I don't know
about 12 Years a Slave was surprisingly
hilarious
from the right angle
I uh yeah can't find the humor in life
and it's worth living is what I say
yeah unless you've lived enough there's
a right bunch of Chuckles in there yes I
grab a couple of large popcorns and uh
extras large slushy get ready to watch
very much watch History yeah
alrighty guys so thanks for being here
and we will uh see you soon
because I am
all right Adrian Tims the killer
Kendrick noise
righteous Ryan Baines ribbed for your
pleasure Rob Frawley II Justice Jeffrey
Robinson righteous real nagas barf and
Barca Fano one jellicle jespreet
Boulevard riff him with Roberto Engelman
holy Heather gear ignite the Ian Simon
shout the Songhai Glover Jesus it's
Jacob Neptune
kooky Kayla the king awesome as always
Alan Ling lovely Logan Burton cook it in
the kitchen here
that's why it sounds
effervescent Eric Hans 39. kite flying
with acoustic
naughty Nick X dirty Dijon January
juicy Juan Longoria girthy Gail Ferguson
clapping Cliff Rodriguez
masturbatori Master T jump on John the
goat looking bastards Lorenzo Baxter
doing stuff differently sane most
tenacious Marco Tunstall loquacious and
hellacious Lauren American Horse so
effin simply faded run kick Rogue Cree
writing essays with
sj-94 just match Johnston Martin running
backwards Rosie Beatty call me
Colin penis Jesus and Sicily Philip K
Smith Jr
hmm
join Scientology Jen Smith milk and
ladies Melanie LeBlanc
you know I already did it it's the job
good theme today John hope other people
picked up on it uh you know I didn't
dictate what the subject matter would be
just what the game parameters could be
so you know it's it's every month that's
that's the thing it's it's a new
experience you never know what's coming
off these domes except a couple of you
who we might have repeated over time
yeah righteous alrighty guys thanks for
being here and being part of our page I
hope to see you all next month thanks
Bane here again